welcome back each year tens of thousands
of people are treated for what the nhs
calls problematic drinking it's an issue
that tears families apart vicky
patterson's father's an alcoholic still
struggling with the disease and live in
the last 10 years of her life in the
public eye she's also known for drinking
excessively she now has a new
documentary out vicki patterson my dad
alcohol and me
vicki thanks for joining us on the show
today now
first of all you're a very well known
face to many people you've been in a
number of reality tv shows including
geordie shaw where you
started that sort of where it all began
for you and then of course she won i'm a
celebrity get me out of here
and i wanted to start off with this you
were a normal girl growing up in
newcastle
turned into this mega
reality tv style was it by accident or
design did is it what you wanted to
happen in your life or just did it
happen to you that was some introduction
that's my best thank you very much
um so
i don't think i ever necessarily wanted
to be
famous like i wasn't a huge
like driving force behind the things i
did i think more than anything i wanted
to be successful i always have wanted to
be
like to do well at whatever i'm doing i
don't love predictability
and i suppose something about this world
i'm in now always appealed to us um but
i don't know if it was the fame it's
probably more the money if i'm honest
well you have become very successful at
what you're doing and i want to get onto
the documentary which is out this month
and i have to say
uh it made me cry
it was very moving i found it a very
moving documentary we could get onto
that in a minute but first i just want
to ask you about uh your time on
geordie's shaw
you said uh it made you into someone
else
when you did it what what do you mean by
that vicky i think when i first went on
geordie show i was really young so i was
about 21 22 and even though i felt so
grown up and you know like i knew it all
which you do at that age i was woefully
unprepared for what i was letting myself
in for and i definitely didn't have the
skills to navigate the space i found
myself in
um i think even before i went on the
show
i had issues with alcohol um and based
on what i've learned from the
documentary i've definitely discovered
my motivations for drinking sort of all
stem
well drinking to excess anyway from when
i feel out of control
when i feel anxious
um in big social situations being in a
in a situation that i don't feel like i
have much control in which is a reality
tv show you know but also they encourage
it do they or did they at the time yeah
i think like you've jordy shaw
did it was exactly what it said on the
tin you know it was chaos and it was a
reality show that promoted
young girls and boys kissing corridor
creeping doing things they probably
shouldn't and probably like drinking a
bit too much i definitely think it
exacerbated the
issues i've got with alcohol but it
certainly wasn't the start okay and
vicki before we get on to the
documentary what what what pulled you
out of geordie's sure what what made you
think
it's time i shouldn't be doing the same
what's not good for me what happened
i i got into a lot of trouble on my time
on geordie shore through being unhappy
out of control and losing all the things
i liked about myself
and i think there was a one particular
pivotal moment where i knew i needed a
break
i was going through a lot personally and
i got told oh after the next series
you're definitely going to have a
prolonged break you can go on holiday
see your family see your friends do
whatever just have a relax
and then they put another series in they
took that breakaway
because it was becoming successful it
was gaining momentum and i get it but i
told them i needed a break i said for my
mental health like i shouldn't really be
doing another series and that's
absolutely fine you can have a break but
you will replace you
and in that moment like i really
believed i was i was working towards
like making something like a huge show
with everybody and actually i just
realized i was very replaceable and
undervalued so that was the beginning of
the end for me
that must have been really hard wasn't
it you said i need a break and they said
fine but we'll replace you it was really
tough
i don't think there is many
there's a lot of more duty of care now
surrounding these shows and quite
rightly so
but back then i don't think we i think
we sort of were
guinea pigs in a way i know those people
who came before with the big brothers
and things like that but our particular
type of reality tv
we were everyone was learning as they
went
would you do it again now
such a it's such a difficult question
answer because obviously i'm super
grateful for where i am now
and i'm not arrogant enough to think i
would have got there
without the catalyst that was jody shaw
i love me platform i love all the
amazing things i get to do
and if it wasn't for georgia i wouldn't
be here
but if i could have got here another way
i think i would have preferred that
well you did get here and then you went
on to when i'm a celebrity and i have to
i'll go and go but just
a couple of things about because i i
love watching that show
um but i do wonder when i watch it is
the reality of it quite monotonous and
boring a lot of the time you've got no
phones no problems
it's honestly no food no booze that is
the hardest bit so everyone thinks it's
like the bugs and don't get me wrong the
heat is horrible especially for like a
little geordie like me and you won i did
i did that feel great
that was the best feeling ever it was
probably validation because nobody
really wanted us in there beforehand why
not
i think everyone like if everyone had
this preconceived notion that i was this
like angry sort of yob from geordie
shore who was going to go in there and i
don't know punch a kangaroo or something
like it was absolutely ridiculous look
let's get on to the the documentary
because that's what you came on to talk
about uh vicki patterson my dad alcohol
and me it says it all in
the title
it's a documentary about your dad uh
who's an alcoholic
the first thing i wanted to ask actually
was was how is your dad now at the
moment um so like i've often said like
the recovery from alcoholism it's not
linear there's always going to be
ups and downs
um and at the moment like my dad's doing
really well he's at my house as we speak
bless him but it was a little bit too
hot for him to get into london today
but no he's doing well um
it's all we can hope for like every day
is a bit of a challenge but yeah he's
he's winning his battle at the moment so
that's that's really good to know
because the documentary is all about
his relationship with our your
relationship with him and his
difficulties his 30-year battle
trying to stop
drinking and failing and succeeding at
different points
and you explore that relationship with
him in
it's an incredibly watchful and moving
documentary
um
the thing that comes out in it is that
this fear that you have that you are
going to become your dad
always worried
because i'm like him in a lot of ways
you know and i
i was aware that i had an addictive
personality i do everything to extreme
extremes if i'm going to go at the gym
i'm going to go five days a week if i'm
going to party i want to be the last one
standing there's no there was never any
balance
so i convinced myself
that it was a foregone conclusion that i
was just going to end up like my dad and
it led us down some real self-sabotaging
paths at times
and vicky you said you you talk in the
documentary about having a complicated
relationship
with alcohol
do you think you're an alcoholic or
could become an alcoholic or you think
it's more nuanced for you and it's about
being mindful
i think um
i think there was
there was a period in my life where
there was a very good chance i could
have ended up being an alcoholic yeah
do you know what's the weirdest thing
when i came out of the jungle everyone
assumed like i had the world at my feet
and i should have been the happiest i've
ever been
but i was really out my death
and i had like raging imposter syndrome
like i didn't believe i deserved
anything i was getting and because i
felt out of place at these big parties
and i was meeting all these big celebs
that i didn't like i'd grew up watching
and i didn't think i deserved to meet i
drank to cope with being quite insecure
and overwhelmed
and it could have easily gotten very out
of control
but my agent stepped in i got a
therapist
i got help
and i think that was a bit of a turning
point for me as well
but i uh i am aware that it's a very
fine line
between
sort of enjoying alcohol for me and not
being able to know when to stop and i
have to work really hard to be on the
right side of that lane so so did you
stop drinking for a while then after you
you drank heavily after i'm then did you
stop once you saw the therapist did you
think i've got to go cold turkey here or
was it never like that for you there's
been i've had periods of sobriety
definitely um more than anything to
prove to myself that i could
um
but no i've never been totally total and
i would like to avoid having to do that
if possible
and but i'm not opposed to it because
you feel you need to yeah definitely
there's other things i want more and
vicki that what what strikes me um in
the documentary is how close you are to
both your parents it's actually lovely
you can see that there is such a
connectivity between you and your mom
and also you and your dad and i wondered
watching it whether
after your mum and dad divorced
it seemed to me that you sort of had to
step in a bit and become
the kind of carer for your dad or take
responsibility in the family
for his alcoholism and trying to fix him
is that kind of what happened and
did you resent that or did you just
accept it as his daughter i wondered
whether it made you angry
there's dorm girls wrong there's been
times in my life where i've i've been
really angry at me dad for being an
alcoholic but i think that showed a lack
of understanding of the disease in
general and i'm sure anybody who is
going through something similar or has
in the past can understand it's an
incredibly frustrating disease
um
but he didn't choose to be this way
and i'm certainly no martyr
like
me mom regardless of whether she was
married to me dad or living with him or
not she's always cared and she's always
been there and vicki i've got i think
we've got a clip actually from the
documentary when you're talking uh to
your mum about how you're feeling i
think can we play that
you know when i went on geordie shore
never thought about what it must be like
for you having to watch me like abuse
alcohol and drink and become that
horrible version of myself
and echo so many
things my dad did
i never thought about that
i didn't like seeing it yeah but i knew
it wasn't you but i never thought you
were late an alcoholic like i did your
dad
i thought she's just young it's gonna
pass it's just when she's in our 20s do
you know what i mean
like i do work really hard you know yeah
to be
this version of me
i would love you to get in the stage
where you don't have to work hard just
be you
yeah oh
bless you i really love you i love you
too
[Music]
i love you mom she's lush isn't joe yeah
she really is
she really is
is that hard he and your mum say that
but also is it getting easier for you do
you think
um
i think i don't think i'll ever like
every time i watch the documentary i
still cry yeah it's
it's a hard watch it is a real
tearjerker for me and like it i can't
remove myself from it it's my life you
know um
and again like my dad's recovery is it's
not all neatly sewn up we're still it's
ongoing so it'll always tug at me
heartstrings but um
no i think
i think i get emotional just because
my family means so much to us
and this documentary means a lot to us
as well you know like i'm i was dead
passionate about making it
i just wanted to ask you just about
your life now because you're you know
you're settled you've got a lovely
boyfriend
you
you know you talk in the documentary
about wanting to get married and have
kids and
but you also talk about being scared
about having kids because you don't
repeat past patterns and also obviously
you can't drink for a number of months
really yeah i mean when i had my babies
it was a bit more relaxed you could have
a couple of drinks but i think now the
recommendation is nothing isn't it
does that scare you that idea or
do you feel more ready now having gone
through the journey of the documentary i
think like years ago
i would have been really intimidated at
the prospect of going like nine ten
months even longer whatever it is
without a drink which is a really um
it's a horrible thing for us to admit
that doesn't make me proud you know
i also was just like really scared like
you say i was just going to have
children who felt in some way
broken
like me
um
but the documentaries brought us a lot
of peace and a lot of clarity
can i say you you do not seem like a
broken person
you really
you're actually the opposite i think
thank you
um
so sorry um
i felt like
and one of my main motivations for
making this documentary was that i had
this strong belief that there was a huge
element of alcoholism that was
completely genetic
that because my dad
had it in him i was just going to have
it in me
and then i truly believed that my kids
would have it too
and i didn't want them to feel different
to everybody else to feel out of control
they feel powerless to stop something
like their life was only ever going obey
one way it was going to be hard and sad
and they were going to hurt people that
loved
so um
that's that was a huge reason why i
haven't had children yet
but now i am in a really good place with
a really nice man and i've done this
documentary and learned loads about this
illness
and i understand there's an element of
it that is learned behavior and
potentially hereditary
but more than that i know we have
choices as well yeah
okay well
thank you for coming on thank you thank
you for doing the documentary because i
think it will
help lots of people out there who have
family members or our colleagues who
have lived through this in some way
and i really enjoyed talking to you so
thanks for coming on thank you so much